[Music]
thank you
what's this with my fashion oh oh yeah
that was another thing so everyone they
liked our um
they liked the vibe of the five year
anniversary show so when we were talking
about the Mr tumness Shoes okay you know
I I described them as being Dior okay
and then you were like oh the tabbies
I'm like that's what they're called
and the amount of people that went
sorry Noelle but those are margielas you
people cannot ever talk [ __ ] about
Cody's clothing the fact that you've
been in the closet and you know what
these Mr tumnis shoes are oh yeah the
margiela tabbies shut up
shut up damn I I thought you were gonna
make fun of me no I don't I don't want
to hear you guys bet the fact that
you're correcting me on the dumbest
shoes ever I don't want to hear you go
in on Cody's attire all right those
shoes are pretty dumb stupid as [ __ ]
nah they are
and I have some dumb shoes yeah I'm
saying I don't want to hear it because
the fact that you are that sort of about
fashion and you wanna you wanna you
wanna turn your nose up at me for not
knowing what the Mr tumnus shoes are
yeah
get out we don't need no high brow ass
opinions on clothing yeah okay yeah you
can't you can't make fun of Cody's
tie-dye glitter combinations okay
just because Cody dresses like a girl in
fourth grade
tie-dye yep check that [ __ ] out I mean
yeah baby I already know okay
I don't want to hear they are right
there I don't want to hear it because
you're sitting here making fun of Cody's
tie-dye but yeah you're probably looking
some out I don't think anyone is dude
what any no one's make you are I don't
want to see you make making fun of
Cody's [ __ ]
third grade girl attire you know
I don't want to see that you can't I
don't wanna I don't want to protect me
and make fun of me in the same thing I
don't want to see you making fun of
Cody's clothing okay which looks like
clothing no it's okay girl that you know
no it's okay
like when you played outside and there
was that girl who smelled like outside
what
what
like you kind of like you you like you'd
all be playing like with all the Kids on
the Block with this one girl pull up and
you're like
smell like leaves why you smell like out
here
and she and I dress like her yeah
that is kind of my inspo
just a little
just a just a little little stank on
there
I don't talk [ __ ] about Cody's clothing
okay if you're out here correcting on
the marzella Tavis
we don't need it thanks bro also
everyone wanted us to bone that last
episode yeah I mean
you were pretty low-key about
um you know saying preach for the love
but we did get a lot of love on that
episode yeah we did and it did feel good
yeah to do that you know and I like that
we're back at the handhelds a little bit
right now I think I think handheld just
changes it
we just got to go back to handheld you
know why when people put mics on arms
they get that like garyvee like
yeah I started gesturing like that and I
think that just like a weird
psychological thing where everyone
starts to feel like what they say like
really [ __ ] important yeah I don't
know what it is about holding a
microphone where it's like
you gotta you gotta like mean what you
say and the monitors too yeah it makes
it feel like more of a conversation
that's for sure
it took us five years and we finally
figured it out yeah
not a podcast
it's like oh just don't
don't do it so hard don't do what you
did for the last two years yeah exactly
if my best friend was a girl I'd marry
him instantly he's the most beautiful
person I know this is not this is not
something I wrote guys this is on Reddit
he's the most beautiful person I know
and he's more attractive than all girls
but like that's gay and I'm straight
I'm so glad we found your burner dude
that's gay
yeah man that's how all bros feel yeah I
wish I could marry you dog yeah that's
that's like a funny uh Instagram comedy
premise that totally tells on yourself
that one bro you definitely marry in the
group all the comments like huh
bro what I don't know if there's a bro
in my group that I'd marry this dude
that one friend that you're low-key
always thinking about [ __ ]
that's also your boy
that that one dude that
like
you would if your family wasn't so
judgmental
huh
bro what is this a meme or are you good
are you okay yeah it's cool man we
support you
what no it's not like I'm that's gay
dude I'm not
I'm not
it's like you would you know
sorry I got nothing that's fine
that's the great part about handheld you
don't have to have anything yeah I feel
like [ __ ] too honestly yeah
yeah man I'm just you want to articulate
why it's over you just had a Halloween's
over I'm excited oh yeah I thought you
were getting so drunk last night because
you were so upset that it's over yeah
that's what it was
I'm just I'm just yeah just sad about
the lack of trick-or-treaters you know
no I'm happy that it's over
my birthday is coming up that's kind of
cool Thanksgiving yo what this is so
funny
no I'm happy that it's over you like say
it like
he just went through something it's a
lot man don't you think yeah no I mean
you were you were the one out there
partying everyone's like worried about
costumes and you gotta it's like a lot
of effort and energy I kept it
then what'd you dress up as nothing
you didn't wear a costume at all did you
have a costume
yeah
Step Brothers we did uh the parents from
everything ever multiple costumes yeah
no it's a lot of effort
yeah I'll tell you what my costume was
what
I wore hamster ears to John and Vinnie's
you went there yesterday no uh Elena and
I took Alex out for like a little
producer lunch okay nice and
Elena just was like too lazy she's like
I'm not wiping off the hamster thing
so I'm like all right well we'll make
you not feel as crazy so I brought the
two additional sets of hamster ears oh
nice and so we had a lunch wearing the
hamster ears oh okay that's cute yeah
that's and then they asked me to move my
car and I took them off
because I was blocking a like an ADA van
unbeknownst to me
it was a sick looking van same hey
hamster guy can you get your car yeah
yeah that's definitely how it felt a
little hey hamster dance over there yeah
yo ass gerbil
move your car
the the dude whose car it was he's cool
as hell you know it's like it's like a
war veteran he apologized to me
I was like that's right yeah probably
because he felt bad yeah he was like oh
sorry you little [ __ ] sorry I had to
interrupt your stupid little lunch
not yeah
no you took a punch him yeah in his
hover around you know he was sitting in
his little four-wheeler
no he was he was a cool dude his van was
was dope I didn't it like had the lifted
aspect so I assume okay
this [ __ ] can definitely get a
wheelchair in here like it's got like
the you know machinery for it yeah but
it was a Kia it was the same color as my
car okay we were matching this [ __ ] was
all blacked out oh nice oh my this van
looks hard damn that's dope
and then yeah they were like hey hamster
[ __ ]
move your car what's the hamster dance
is that what it is yeah yeah
remember that dumbass picture that F1
car
[Music]
Crazy Frog
yeah but it was just that oh okay
sequence under the image of an F1 card
oh that was like a link on evam's world
you just click that and then just watch
I've seen it then that sound right with
that image so stupid man